pensez déjà des marseillais et cette
polémique avec ses poissons dont le
jacuzzi regarde passer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors ça ça il dormait m'en vais réagir
est ce que ça vous a choqué ou pas sur
le plateau
alors non mais alors derrière je voulais
juste vous dire cette séquence à fait
normal a fait et non non et agir
notamment l'eau silva mais si c'est un
poisson dans l'eau chaude et jacuzzi un
des poids soirée sans discrimination on
les met dans l'eau oui mais là ils ont
alors qu ils sont pas morts là vous dis
des bêtises
regardez motion finale il ya 30 millions
d'amis car elle qui a réagi des poissons
jeté dans un jacuzzi plein de mousse
dans l'émission décidé dans le respect
des animaux des années mon cas ça n'est
vraiment pas la priorité du groupe m6
hashtag maltraitance animale
voilà la fondation brigitte bardot sied
on aimerait trop divertis par la télé on
aime encore plus critique et donc
d'hypocrites que vous êtes mdr occupez
vous des choses plus graves au le nous
casser les couilles
ça c'est le tweet d'anthony matteo des
matérias le code de kelly est un garçon
qui est un garçon a été réussi mais
c'est un garçon charmant qui a pu péter
les plombs
mais est-ce que vous est ce que ça vous
a choqué ou pas y arriver il perd alors
à du tome est juste un hyper choqué
vincent ouais je suis hyper choqué très
nettement mois tout ce qui touche aux
animaux je suis j'en ai deux je défend
énormément la fondation bardot
[Rires]
on dit des animaux mais c'est des
crustacés évident les recettes et crabes
non mais peu importe pourquoi on serait
moins triste pour des poissons que pour
un mouton à jeudi ce sont les animaux
sont des êtres vivants aux animaux je
suis pas bien et je défends 200 mx la
ville at il dit ils ont même pas de sang
les donneurs et nabila ce soir c'est
nabila cousteau c'est la ville à se
rendre compte j'ai dit je vais l'emmener
à la pêche au thon birsa nabila c'est
franchement ça saigne énormément donc
jean luc lennon mais la raison j'avais
trouvé du sang quand j'ai coupé en
poisson pané donc
[Applaudissements]
alors je vais choquer ou pas si ça
m'ennuie beaucoup mais je suis en
désaccord pour une fois avec may be là
bas si je suis extrêmement choqué on ne
touche pas aux poissons rouges
franchement c'est pas moi c'est les
poissons me toucher